Vsauce Michael here to tell you that
episode three of Leanback is ready this
week the topic is temperature from very
high to very low it's a television show
length playlist that I host containing
videos from people all over YouTube
now this one's kind of sciency this time
but I think the videos that make it up
are pretty awesome no matter what now
because I can't send a playlist out to
you the way I can upload a video you're
going to have to click the first topmost
link in this video's description to get
things rolling if you're on a phone
playlists might not work and if you
can't wait for a better time to leave
back I've put links to every video in
the playlist down below and if you have
a site and you want to embed this entire
experience guess what the description
has the code you need so what are you
waiting for to get it started and let
the videos play themselves and the
internet do the work get some knowledge
click the link and as always thanks for
watching
[Music]